are allegations of ethnic cleansing and
war crimes in ethiopia being ignored
rights groups accuse security forces of
atrocities in the tigrai region
ethiopian government leaders say the
allegations could fuel racial hatred so
what should the response be
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum
mass killings rape torture people
deprived of food and forcibly
transferred they're some of the most
serious allegations from almost 18
months of war in the tagrai region of
northern ethiopia amnesty international
and human rights watch say evidence of
ethnic cleansing and war crimes is being
ignored internationally
their joint report focuses on the
western tigrai zone it accuses officials
and security forces from the neighboring
amhara region of a coordinated campaign
against tegran people
fighting since late 2020 has so far
killed thousands of people and forced
many more to seek refuge in neighboring
sudan and eritrea amnesty international
and human rights watch are calling for
the deployment of peacekeepers led by
the african union to protect civilians
and accused the ethiopian government of
blocking aid workers and investigators
from the war zone
we have documented
extrajudicial executions
arbitrary and other unlawful
killings
forceful forced expulsions torture and
other forms of ill treatment
rape and sexual violence
destruction and looting of property and
mass arbitrary arrests
that amount to crimes against humanity
and war crimes
ethiopia's government is pledging to
make the guilty accountable but says
what it calls the report's ethnic
undertones could fuel hatred and that
the report's recommendations aren't
helpful to peace efforts the amhara
regional government is dismissing the
war crimes allegations as lies
let's remind you of the main events in
this conflict so far
fighting began in november 2020 when
ethiopia's prime minister ordered a
military offensive against the tigray
people's liberation front abe ahmed said
he was responding to attacks on army
bases
following months of fighting tegrian
fighters recaptured the regional capital
mikhail in june
by july the tplf entered the neighboring
amhara and afar regions to the south
in october the government launched a
ground offensive to repel the rebels
they responded by recapturing the city
of lalibella
thousands have been killed and more than
two million people forced from their
homes
ethiopia's government declared a
unilateral truce last month to allow
much needed aid to be delivered to
degray
with regards to the situation in
ethiopia tigre in particular of course
we are
we can only be pleased about the truth
that has been announced and
we have managed over the weekend for the
first time in many months to bring a
convoy
with 200 metric tons of humanitarian
assistance by road into tigre
with food with especially medical
supplies but also non-food items
all right let's bring in our guests from
ethiopia we're joined by anne fitzgerald
she's the director of the baal silly
school of international affairs in
canada and has worked in ethiopia for
more than 20 years on issues concerning
conflict security and governance
in kenya's capital nairobi leticia bader
horn of africa director with human
rights watch and a contributor to the
report
in amsterdam in the netherlands gabriel
kirstos gabriele selassie a writer and
researcher and the founder and editor of
tgot.com that's a website documenting
the war integrai
a warm welcome to you all and thanks so
much for joining us today latisha let me
start with you today these are very
disturbing allegations that are outlined
in this report
from your group human rights watch and
amnesty international could you please
detail some of the other major findings
in this report for our audience
well basically this is based on over a
year of research which started at the
outbreak of the conflict
speaking to refugees who were fleeing
from western tigre in in november and
december 2020 and what we find and we
document in this report are waves of
very serious crime against the tigran
population in western tigre in the first
phase between november and december 2020
we document primarily war crimes by
ethiopian federal government forces
alongside a our special forces and
militia during the initial offensive in
this region and then from december 2020
onwards we document waves of what we
have described and found to be a
campaign an organized campaign of ethnic
cleansing and as part of that campaign
we document a whole range of very
serious abuses extrajudicial killings
sexual violence mass incarceration in
horrific detention conditions and then
the force expulsions of hundreds of
thousands of tigrayans from this area
that that had been their home
and from your perspective have you had a
chance to read the report um and what do
you think about its findings
i think the objective of the report is
um very sound to investigate something
that uh reflects
gross human rights violations and
atrocities
that said i uh
i guess i'm wearing my research hat and
i would um ask some questions that are
methodological in nature so the
researchers did not go to the area where
the evidence
existed in the wall kite region itself
secondly there were over
400 in fact i think 427 interviews
orchestrated and that's a very good
number
however on close examination of the
footnotes it seems that
the evidence that lent to the analysis
was heavily weighted to the interviews
undertaken by the researchers when they
were on the ground in
sudan and of course we know that
the groups in sudan at the time
not only included ethnic tehran groups
that were unfortunately and tragically
displaced from
um to gray proper but also
the sahmri youth arm of the tplf
fighters
which reports
suggest
orchestrated the killings in my cadre uh
deaths which uh the number continues to
grow but
number over twelve hundred so that was
the first methodological like question i
had there were telephone calls that were
made to
um
ethnic amara from the region of wall
kite but these were small in number and
we don't get a sense of number and we
don't
see that reflected so much in the report
i think the other thing is that there's
a big study by gondara university on
this very issue which has been ongoing
for over a year and research principles
command a literature review at the front
end anybody who's an expert on these
issues and it's just strange that um
there's no reference to that report and
the publication of this report has been
unleashed
two days before the planned publication
and launch of the gandara university
report on those mass graves i guess the
last thing i'll say is that um
the content to me does not lend to the
findings to draw such
huge conclusions
that um
that that accuse others of war crimes
and ethnic cleansing
needs a very deep investigation and a
methodologically sound and robust
investigation so i do feel that there's
a slightly weak link between the content
of the report
and the findings uh leticia ann seems to
have some misgivings with the
methodology um would you like to respond
to what she was saying
yeah i'm very happy to i mean first of
all as we described very clearly in the
methodology
our research was ongoing until january
2022 in the course of that a lot of what
we document i mean the waves of abuses
which happened from from december 2020
onwards were at a time where the federal
government forces and the militia were
actually preventing people from fleeing
into sudan so a lot of the research
which was done in sudan was on the early
phases of the conflict including of very
detailed descriptions also of of what
happened in my cabra
but but a lot of that the subsequent
research was actually done with
individuals who were forcibly exposed as
part of really this organized cap
campaign of ethnic cleansing which
started from december 2020 onwards and i
mean also we have corroborated a lot of
our testimonial findings with satellite
imagery including of the destructions of
entire villages as well as the movement
of these organized convoys here we're
talking about individuals who were in
detention facilities who were being
taken from detention facilities and bust
across into to the takiza river area
which is seen as the natural boundary
between these two parts of tigre but
we're also talking about people
who are coerced into leaving they've
been living in a context of abuses of
fear of increasing discrimination
against tigrans we have a lot of detail
in here in terms of what little
humanitarian assistance was going into
this area this was an area where the
ethiopian government was in control of
giving out assistance was
instrumentalized and that was used as
one of the tools by discriminatory
preventing tigrans from having access to
that making the context in which they
were living in almost impossible to
survive in so
i think i think we can go on in on on
methodology for a long time i mean
ethiopia is a country where uh human
rights watch at least for for decades
has been doing remote research in this
is a context we are very used to
operating in this type of of of of of um
of context uh
um
have you read the full report and if so
do you believe that it gives the full
most comprehensive picture of what's
going on on the ground or do you think
that there's there's more that that
needs to be reported
thank you
um
yes i did
and
i'm happy that this report
has started to scratch the surface of
the
crimes committed into dry
but um
it does have
also a lot of limitations
uh some of it
uh imposed by the
government deliberately didn't allow
like ann was saying now that you know
they didn't go there well the reason
they didn't go there is because the
government has uh a policy of uh total
blockade and communications blackout to
make sure that no voice comes out of the
guy
but it has also this problem of sticking
to previous uh
amnesty report
which was really a dangerous report that
victimizes the very victims of the
grands uh as perpetrators of crimes
even if you know the
ethiopian and their allies were on the
ninth of november in my alcadra we've
written a lot about this uh but the uh
the report still sticks that uh you know
because it wants to stick to the
previous uh amnesty report that they
entered uh
my cadre on the nines and uh you know
the grants were involved in some
conflict before
the truth is that the european
government orchestrated this crime using
amnesty uh to propagate this narrative
that the grants were committing crimes
and it uses that report to galvanize
ethiopians against the brands now
another thing that this report misses is
the bigger context so really what is
happening here is that tigray as a
result of its history and its place in
ethiopia and in europe
pre-history is being
uh wiped out uh
as a policy of both governments in fact
three governments
as some kind of
independent actor so what are they
trying to do is they are trying to uh
not only uh eliminate
uh as a region as a state but also they
are trying to
either totally eliminate the the grand
people or reduce them according to their
words to about a million people that
don't cause any threat to both ethiopia
and eritrea and this is i think the
bigger policy that the report misses hey
gabriel here i just want to follow up
with you about something uh you know the
ethiopian government declared that there
was an indefinite humanitarian truce
they declared that in in late march um
is is that actually holding is aid
actually getting into degrade right now
no um the eight is not getting into the
gray uh they only let about 21 uh tracks
only to reset the narrative that is to
kind of like uh they got the news they
got the image that ed is getting into
today we are now more than two weeks
since they announced that they only
allowed one day uh 21 trucks
while we know that about 100 trucks are
supposed to intertwine every day so they
have got the image they have got the
narrative um uh in the international
media that the aid is getting into the
grind but the policy is like i said
before
reducing the cigarette population
through starvation massacres ethnic
cleansing and it is working every second
every minute every uh hour and they are
succeeding in this
and um i want to talk a little bit about
the um
the political picture in ethiopia right
now how complicated things are and also
what actually has to happen for this
conflict to come to an end
yeah i'd just like to say first of all
that um forensic criminal evidence is
required for this investigation into the
mass graves and that's the sort of thing
that needs to be done to find
conclusions and recommendations of the
sort that the report has put forward and
that has yet to be done and is
desperately needed secondly um uh in in
line with your question i've just spent
considerable time across the northern
regions of ethiopia i have witnessed the
um
huge levels of destruction and damage
caused by the fighting left by the
tigrayan fighters i have witnessed
numerous mass graves so the mass graves
in wall kite are certainly not the only
mass grave and an investigation is going
to happen
on mass graves it should be
comprehensive
and uh thirdly uh there are considerable
numbers of terrain fighters still
occupying
five regions in northern afr for any
humanitarian truce to be successful
those troops have to pull back
there are many of them and triangulated
research across hundreds that were
interviewed from these communities
suggests numbers from 80 000 to 100 000
and the use of artillery and heavy
weapons there is no scope for a
humanitarian truce or aid delivery in
those circumstances secondly this war is
not only affecting tigre it is affecting
three regions i visited idp camps that
are starving of food and water at the
moment while the trucks that my fellow
panelists referred to go past and go up
to the region there's great pressure for
that aid to get to tigurai and that is
terribly important um the chagrins who i
interviewed who have come to the idp
camps across the border have not had
food for a long time but um there
there are three communities here
affected by the conflict three regional
states
and i would summarize by saying
that until the military activity is
drawn to a conclusion and troops are
drawn back there can be no humanitarian
solution because humanitarian goals are
incompatible with military insurgency
goals and there are a vast number of
troops still across the five regions of
afar
so we are seeing it seems one side honor
its commitment to humanitarian truths at
the moment but not the other party to
the conflict letitia ethiopia's
government is pledging to make the
guilty accountable um are you getting
indications after the publication of the
report are you getting indications from
government officials that that is
actually going to happen
well i mean maybe to follow up on one of
the points anne made which i i would say
i would agree with um one of the big
recommendations in this report is the
need for ongoing international
independent investigations and as part
of that there needs to be forensic
expertise one of the concerns we have
with how long
getting
international investigations up and
running into the abuses in the whole of
northern ethiopia is that we have
documented incidents of destruction of
physical evidence and there is an
expertise which is required for the
retrieval of bodies including ensuring
that this is done in a way which is
dignified as well so we absolutely agree
and we have actually continued to call
we we
um advocated for a new commission at the
level of the human rights council in
geneva to really look into this and to
collect evidence preserve evidence in in
a humane dignified manner um to for
future accountability um i also just
want to come to this the question of the
humanitarian truce i mean under
international humanitarian law that does
not need to be a truce for
warring parties to allow unhindered
humanitarian access and and i think it
is important to continue to underline
that what we have been seeing in tigre
in particular and the ongoing
obstruction of humanitarian assistance
going in
as a result of federal government
policies and actions but also regional
authorities security forces etc this
constitutes you know an effective siege
and is a violation in itself and i think
it's important to continue to underline
that humanitarian access cannot be used
as a political tool it should not be
used as a consensus building measure it
is a responsibility of all the warring
parties to allow that going in in terms
of commitments to investigations i mean
we have in our report um looked into
what we have heard so far i mean one of
the big concerns with west antigua is
this is in many ways the elephant in the
room it is very contested it is very
complicated but we've also heard very
early on in in at the height of the the
beginning of the ethnic cleansing
campaign denials from the federal
government and the regional authorities
in the amhara region
um and so you know it is it is positive
to hear the government is going to look
into our findings but it is absolutely
key that we continue to see and we we
see the opening up of a space for
credible international and regional
investigations in into what has been
happening as well
gabriel kirstos from your perspective
why hasn't more action been taken by the
international community
thank you i just want to respond uh to
some of the points
the ethiopian government is the
main
engineer of this
genocide it has a policy
uh on how to implement this i'm not
looking at this they even have told the
european envoy pekka harvey store about
their plan to wipe the tigrans i'm
quoting what they say to him to wipe the
tigrans
400 years to destroy them for 100 years
and this is to what they say to him what
we hear in the amharic language every
day is just
how to eliminate the terrain this is an
open discussion how to uh
wipe them out this is just everyone
talks yamaha authorities talk openly on
media so really what we are talking here
i don't know why we beautify things you
know this is a policy of genocide and
it is uh
everything that happens the a the
blockade is all uh you know part of the
the plan to completely wipe out the
tigrans in the long term so ann was
talking previously you know about uh
that grants coming out of uh tigray uh
that is also the policy to to first lacy
to them and then to disperse them and
this is uh this has been tried by the
way in 1984 by the communist government
now it's at a larger scale so we don't
miss that big picture so how do you
expect the ethiopian government to
why do you recommend to the ethiopian
government to act it is the the very
entity the very engineer of this
genocide so that's one thing the the the
other reason why the international
community is not acting unfortunately
tigray doesn't have a lot of global
interest and sadly it has been allowed
to die
while at the same time you know once in
a while saying uh some words like you
know they are concerned but effectively
they know that this is a genocide the
u.s knew about this long time ago about
the west antigua ethnic placing for
example but there is no action in fact
today they are signing one more under a
movement
of understanding with european companies
un you know it's all business as usual
because the guy is not even producing uh
refugees to be seen the the siege the
blockade the communications blackout
have shielded the water from seeing what
is happening
i'm sorry
i'm sorry to interrupt but we're just
about out of time i want to ask ann one
last question here uh and we just have
about a minute left uh amnesty
international human rights watch are
both calling for the deployment of
peacekeepers led by the african union to
protect civilians is that something you
think might happen
i don't know
the deployment of peacekeepers would
require agreement on all sides that's a
fundamental principle of international
peacekeeping i do think that
what we are seeing now is a combination
of conventional conflict and insurgency
conflict still insurgency shaped by a um
a serious information campaign with
misinformation and disinformation and
what i would recommend is not
peacekeepers
uh so long as both sides respect a human
humanitarian truce and the tplf fighters
withdraw from afar but i think some
verification and monitoring is
desperately required so an independent
verification and monitoring
uh force
um would be uh au led this is an african
issue this is for the african continent
to uh support and resolve um but i think
something that verifies information
misinformation is uh vital
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests ann fitzgerald leticia
bader and gabriel kirstos gabriel
selassie
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
mohammed jim joham and the whole team
here in doha bye for now
you